[Applaudissements]
bonsoir il ya quelques années un éditeur
m'a appelé va proposer déjeuner avec lui
puisque j'écris des livres aussi il me
dit voilà pierre sympa ce que tu fais on
aimerait bientôt d'avoir dans notre
collection d'autres dans notre maison
d'édition on a regardé un peu tes les
tirages de tes livres
c'est sympa mais il ya quand même un
décalage entre ta surface médiatique et
la vente de thé livre tu n'as pas la
vente de livres qui correspond à sa
surface médiatique
donc on aimerait de porter plus loin et
de porter vers 30 35 mille exemplaires
pour ton prochain et c'est très très
bien sachant que je plafonne 15000 16000
quand on dit ça un auteur il va pas dire
non pas du tout savez je préfère rester
très modestes en super ceci dit je
l'attendais quand même un peu au
tournant et dîners tu vois ton problème
c'est que tunis terrisse pas le débat
tunis terrisse pas le débat les bouquins
qui marche aujourd'hui c'est ce qui
hisse terry's le débat d'ailleurs ce qui
tourne résolument le dos à une recherche
d'un juste milieu
c'est ça qui fonctionne jeudi j'ai
écouté vachement sympa très très bien en
fait cette donne plein d'idées parce que
je réalise encore plus à quel point ce
que je sais l'hystérisation vous et des
bas
donc je vais voir un autre notre éditeur
mon livre est quand même rentrer dans la
liste des best-sellers de l'express en
18e position
j'ai pas fait trente cinq mille
exemplaires mais je suis en tout cas de
conforme à mon juste milieu intérieur
alors pour poursuivre la réflexion sur
ce thème que j'ai trouvé très riche qui
m'a vraiment intéressé qui m'a fait
gamberger et je me suis dit finalement
s'il y a un juste milieu quelque part
est ce qu'il y a un un juste milieu
raisonnement par l'absurde
je me suis souvenu que les gendarmes les
magistrats parlent du milieu à propos du
grand banditisme
donc j'ai exclu cette piste là ce milieu
là ne m'a pas semblé intéressant pour
essayer de dégager quelque chose de
juste ou de positif plus sérieusement je
me suis souvenu qu'au 19e siècle
on parlait de la chine en parlant de l'
empire du milieu
ça c'est une piste intéressante
est-ce que ce milieu-là peut donner des
pistes de
de réflexion le problème de nos amis
chinois du 19e siècle
c'est qu'avec la conception de l' empire
du milieu
ils ont cru enfermés dans les hautes
murailles de la cité interdite
ils ont cru que le reste du monde était
finalement satellite de leur milieu de
leurs centralité donc ils n'ont pas du
tout perçu que le monde notamment au
milieu du 19e siècle bouger énormément
qu'il y avait la révolution industrielle
ils sont passés complètement à côté de
la révolution industrielle
parce que si vous êtes finalement dans
une approche non pas vers le juste
milieu
mais vers le nombrilisme voyez pas ce
qui se passe autour et donc en fait l'
empire du milieu chinois est devenu une
proie pour les occidentaux notamment et
nous avons découpé de larges tranches
dans l' empire du milieu qui s'est
retrouvé occupée et ne vous y trompez
pas dans les ambitions de jean ping le
nouveau mao mao particulier puisque ils
marient à la fois philosophie de mao et
d'une approche business marketing
extrêmement puissante mais dans la
volonté chinoise aujourd'hui d'être
véritablement demain la puissance
dominante
c'est aussi une façon d'effacer les
traces des blessures des traumatismes
liés à la destruction finalement de
cette conception centrale autocentré de
l' empire du milieu donc
je ne propose pas de suivre l'exemple de
la de la chine
mais cette idée dampierre du milieu je
vais trouver intéressante parce que
malheureusement nous sommes dans une
époque où cette approche du monde c'est
à dire de l' empire du milieu est
quelque chose qui s'est considérablement
développée et que l'on voit maintenant à
travers toute une série de pays avec un
mouvement en ciseau ce qui monte c'est
l'extension du domaine de l' empire du
milieu
ceux qui descendent ce sont les
structures internationales de dialogue
qui essaye au contraire de trouver des
juste milieu des endroits où se
réconcilier et vous parlez donc on a un
mouvement en biseau ce sont quoi les
nouveaux empire du milieu
c'est l'amérique de trump america first
mais qui est américain
alone en fait seul - seul le reste du
monde
c'est la chine de xi jingping aussi
centralité chinoise le reste doit le
reste on peut faire du business avec lui
mais reste marginal
c'est l'artiste la turquie d'erdogan
avec là aussi une volonté de
restauration ottomane alors non pas au
sens géographique de la sublime porte et
de l' empire ottoman
mais la psychologie qu mans c'est ce
qu'on retrouve chez poutine
c'est ce qu'on a également schéma du
rouge du trt chez molson araud on peut
encore citer encore beaucoup d'autres
mohamed ben salman donc l'homme fort qui
veut faire de l'arabie saoudite et des
lieux saints finalement le centre d'un
empire du milieu sunnite
donc ma belle-mère salman l'homme qui
pratique le journalisme à la découpe
donc ce sont des nouvelles des nouvelles
formes finalement impériale ou au nom
d'un milieu qui devient un gouffre
centrale d'ambition le reste devient
périphérique et le problème c'est que
nous avons aujourd'hui véritablement des
poussées des remontées de ce côté là et
vous avez un lien entre eux finalement
les nouveaux empereur et c'est empire du
milieu
les nouveaux empereur des personnages
que j'ai cités ce sont souvent des
imprécateurs donc des personnes qui sont
dans des rapports hystérique aux autres
poutine et erdogan dans un des livres
que j'avais commencé il ya quelques
années il était extrêmement copains ils
partageaient des tas de points de vue
sur le monde
et puis à erdogan a commis l'erreur
d'abattre un avion de combat russes
et donc c'était des affrontements
verbaux réellement hystérique on a
rarement vu dans les relations
internationales de la part de poutine
fin de la part d'un chef d'état comme
poutine le fait d'agresser verbalement
un autre chef d'état on le traitant de
tous les noms d'oiseaux
que dire de trump qui se saisit de
duffort delà de la scène de l'assemblée
générale des nations unies où il est
interdit dans les règlements d'agresser
d'insultés de menaces et un autre pays
et qui menace la corée du nord de
destruction de faire passer la corée du
nord par le fer et le feu
tout ça quelques temps avant de trouver
que finalement celui qu'il appelait
rocket man rocket man est devenu un
personnage tout à fait sympathique il a
le feeling avec lui sachant qu'il ya une
certaine convergence capillaires qu'il
est qui la rapproche travers des styles
assez assez différent enfin tout cas
c'est un terrain un terrain d'entente
donc après l'hystérie peut y avoir une
période d'accalmie mais ça n'est pas
très rassurant le problème de fond chez
ces nouveaux empereur du milieu du
centre du gouffre c'est que ce sont des
personnages qui ont plus de croyance que
de connaissances
c'est un point très important je ne
pense pas qu'on puisse trouver un
terrain d'entente
un juste milieu compris comme étant un
point d'équilibré entre des points de
vue différents
si vous avancez surtout avec des
croyances et avec peu de connaissances
la connaissance permet de s'entendre de
discuter d'essayer d'être d'accord sur
une analyse commune sur six possibles
des faits qui ne soient pas des faits
déformés ou des vérités alternative
or nous avons de plus en plus de chefs
d'états et de gouvernements à travers le
monde qui ont une dose de croyance très
forte ce qui complique considérablement
le boulot des diplomates qui sont
chargés justement sur des sujets
complexes de trouver des points
d'entente mais à partir des bases
communes
et quand on voit le fonctionnement de
ces différents personnages que j'ai
évoqué ce sont des personnages et s'est
qualifié dans un de mes livres de
personnages messianique autoproclamé
personnage messianique autoproclamé
c'est compliqué les personnages
messianique
pourquoi parce qu'ils estiment que le
doigt de dieu et sur leur tête qui sont
investis d'une mission quasi divine
c'est vrai aussi pour jean ping alors
c'est pas le doigt de dieu c'est le
doigt de mao
mais la problématique psychologique est
la même et quand vous discutez quand
vous négociez quand des diplomates
négocier avec ses personnages ou leur
entourage
c'est complexe parce que la croyance est
en pointe par rapport à la connaissance
et à la conte et à la compréhension et
cette extension du domaine psychologique
de l' empire du milieu le fait de se
considérer comme central sa rentrée
compliquée l'altérité
le fait de rentrer dans un système
d'altérité je vais partager avec vous
une histoire vraie à l'époque où bush
junior présider aux destinées des états
unis il ya eu le drame du 11 septembre
avec
cette volonté des américains qui avaient
constaté que dans les avions terroristes
des allemands kamikazes
il y avait essentiellement des saoudiens
et qui ont donc pris la décision très
logique l'attaqué l'irak avant que ça ne
se fasse
le président chirac le prince a précédé
en france et chirac a dépêché auprès de
bush auprès des équipes de bouche des
diplomates pour essayer de les ramener à
la raison en disant tu es regarder
l'enseignement de bush père inquiet
surtout éviter de déstabiliser
complètement le le pays
donc évitons d'entrée en il se trouve
que mes amis était un des diplomates
proches de jacques chirac et que un de
ces retours je trouve complètement
effondré donc c'était avant la fameuse
invasion libération du mois de mars 2003
moment quand le x ou la france essayait
de faire valoir les inspections de l'onu
c'est-à-dire le rôle des forces qui
cherchent le juste milieu et je vois
cette amie kim éclairer un peu sur les
dessous du dossier et je le trouve
complètement effondré et me dit écoute
le problème pierre c'est que la
prochaine fois il faudra que j'aille
là-bas avec un marabout
oui parce que effectivement nos
discussions se situent à un niveau qui
est vraiment dépasse mes compétences de
diplomate
parce que quand je discute avec certains
proches du président
américain en faisant valoir des éléments
de connaissance sur les rapports de
force les chiites des sunnites
la géopolitique de la région la
déstabilisation accessoirement le fait
que ben laden qui est normalement
normalement le commanditaire c'est
plutôt un saoudien une grande famille
saoudienne et cetera il me regarde et me
disent donc je donne pas son prénom pour
des indications charles un coup tu as
peut-être raison mais ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que l'on septembre
c'est une punition divine
les etats-unis ont oublié leur vocation
messianique
ils ont été frappés pour cela je rentre
pas dans le détail mais vous voyez à ce
stade là il est extrêmement compliqué
d'arriver à s'ajuster se comprendre et
déboucher les américains d'ailleurs
continuer sur cette lancée on inventé
les armes de destruction massive et donc
vous avez véritablement ce tournant qui
a été pris et qui est une façon vraiment
de refuser le juste milieu
il faut dire que nicolas tout à l'heure
à parler de la peur
plus on a peur plus on est stressé plus
la tendance va être de refuser le juste
milieu
le juste milieu c'est un point de
complexité ça passe par l'acceptation de
points de vue différents voire
contradictoires
c'est une recherche dynamique or la
radicalité a fortiori le totalitarisme
qui incarne par exemple des ch
c'est très confortable surtout les
travaux ont été faits même des
débriefings des services de
renseignements sur les kamikazes tamment
qui ne sont pas mortes ont été capturés
par la suite ou par un certain nombre
d'occidentaux qui se sont radicalisées
qui sont partis vers donc le sunnisme
radical intégristes et pianiste une
démotivation qui ressort c'est au moins
cette religion me dit où est la limite
droite la limite de gauche me disent
qu'ils aient validé ce qui ne l'est pas
et finalement dans un monde complexe
c'est reposant accessoirement les jeunes
filles sont jeunes filles occidental
se sont radicalisées sur internet et qui
sont partis épousé à vienne où ailleurs
un moudjahidine dont l'espérance de vie
était de 6 mois expliquez moi ça me
change des mecs occidentaux n'ont pas de
couilles
au moins là j'ai un viril j'ai un
guerrier sait ce qu'il veut donc c'est
pas du tout le juste le juste le juste
milieu
alors si je poursuis mon chemin pour
essayer de voir quels sont les pierres
blanches pour travailler ce juste milieu
parce que je crois que plus nous sommes
dans des périodes hystérique de tension
avec un fort retour de ce que j'appelle
la barbarie sens large
tiens un affaiblissement des structures
qui font civilisation comme les
instances internationales que ce soit
l'onu l'unesco l'om c'est le conseil de
coopération du golfe
l'union européenne qui a un certain
nombre de trous donc toutes ces
structures qui font juste milieu qui
travaillent sur le juste milieu qui sont
en perte de vitesse
il faut véritablement se battre si on
estime justement que le juste milieu est
une réponse à l'hystérisation
l'hystérisation dont le point final
c'est la guerre vous savez que frei de
10 et la civilisation a commencé le jour
où un être humain
au lieu d'envoyer un caillou à la gueule
de son vis-à-vis le envoyé une insulte
c'est à dire c'était le début de la
dématérialisation de la violence donc on
peut espérer qu'après l'insultent il a
voulu commencer à discuter avec celui là
c'est ça la civilisation s'est quitté
notre cerveau reptilien qui absolument
envie d'en découdre avec ceux qui n'ont
pas la même tête que nous pour chercher
un juste milieu
donc là on a véritablement des enjeux
qui nous concerne tous et vous jeunes
générations vous êtes en plein dedans
alors suis d'accord avec nicolas on vous
laisse pas nécessairement un monde
désastreux il ya des avantages et des
inconvénients et puis surtout vous avez
des forces de créativité que vous
pourrez faire jouer et qu'ils nous
surprennent déjà aujourd'hui qui nous
reprendrons demain en même temps ce
monde est devenu très compliqué très
complexe d'où la nécessité de chercher
avec encore plus d'acharnement et de
détermination ce juste milieu
quels sont les pierres blanches qu'on
peut trouver là dedans que j'essaie de
comment dirais-je d'incorporer moi même
dans mon travail avec peut-être une base
une base venue de l'enfant ce qui fait
que j'ai toujours beaucoup détester la
suprématie de mon frère aîné donc ce
phénomène de domination est en position
numéro deux dans une famille de quatre
garçons et donc finalement je trouve ça
tout à fait injuste et je crois qu assez
naturellement peut-être aussi ce qui à
mon tempérament
j'ai cherché d'autres positions des
juste milieu pour éviter l' hégémonie de
mon frère et après j'ai travaillé ça y
compris en étant officiers de réserve
engagé sur des théâtres de guerre
afghanistan balkans en afrique etc ou là
l'hystérie le refus juste milieu est
flagrant puisque en fait on va les tuer
l'autre qui est différent sur les
pierres blanches
je voulais dit je le répète la force des
connaissances donc internet très bonnes
choses sur internet mais les réseaux
sociaux la violence les fake news etc
travail et la connaissance c'est ce qui
permet de se recentrer ce qui permet
aussi de dialoguer avec des personnes
différentes pour trouver ce point
d'accord
la dernière chose en quasi conclusion je
voudrais vous proposer
finalement à travers un oxymore soyez
soyons des nomades enracinée soyons des
nomades enraciné jeu j'essaye d'être un
nomade enracinée je suis français
j'adore mon pays je suis très patriote
et parce que je suis enraciné
je suis nomades c'est notamment nomades
du côté de l'union européenne et même
ailleurs c'est parce que je sais d'où je
viens où je suis gay sont mes racines
que je suis extrêmement tranquille pour
me balader et être nomade donc soyez
enracinée là où vous voulez en fonction
de votre histoire
mais soyez nomades dans le sens où par
rapport aux sujets qui a été posée
finalement est-ce qu'on trouve le juste
milieu je ne sais pas parfois on passe
dessus on repasse ce que je crois que
c'est que il faut chercher toute sa vie
finalement essence et en ayant cet
esprit nomade de rechercher d'aller à la
rencontre que on va parvenir à agréger
en somme de choses qui vont ressembler
momentanément un juste milieu
dernier point si vous ne vous y fiez pas
si vous ne faites pas un travail qui est
un travail de toute une vie pour trouver
votre propre intériorité votre propre
juste milieu peut-être au pluriel parce
qu'après il faut essayer d harmoniser
vous aurez beaucoup de mal à le faire à
l'extérieur sur des sujets plus
compliqué plus plus plus difficile
quel que soit l'univers professionnel
dans lequel vous vous trouverez soyez
des nomades bouger transformez-vous et
en même temps et y ait des racines
solides
c'est tout le mal que je vous souhaite
[Applaudissements]